hi hi i mean
we have been watching your family but
i know so much of the recent
sort of conversations are about one of
the
last seasons or that it is the last
season
how do you feel about that do you feel
good indifferent bad free
no you know it's definitely really
bittersweet
um being doing the show for 20 seasons
and
i think 11 different spin-offs um it was
such a blessing and an honor to do
but having that chapter be closed i was
so
i don't like change so i for me i took
it the hardest that we were stopping it
but
i think we needed to just close that
chapter in a
really in a way where we're deciding to
instead of
people deciding for us now is it true
that you used to have a crush on
christian bale
oh my gosh yes
how do you know these things oh my gosh
um
christian bale i don't know if you've
seen the movie newsies have you seen
that yeah yeah it's a musical and he's
singing and he's wearing a newsboy
cap and it's not even like the sexiest
version of himself but i was just like
oh
love and then of course he just got more
and more
sexier the more i think adults
wild rules he would play okay so i went
uh like on a faux date with him when i
was like i don't know 10 years old i
went to visit steven spielberg on that
not name dropping
um on the set of empire of the sun and
christian bale was the star of that but
he was also like 10-2 we went to like
the hard rock cafe in london it was like
super fun but i remember like beating
myself
up when he became like a teenager like
why didn't i see it then i could have
married him right then and there
oh my god i wish you did oh what a good
story would that have been
but yeah he became like the most dynamic
man
ever and i remember being like you
should have seen it when he was 10 years
old
oh my god he just me was always so
handsome but yes respectfully i know
he's married this was
of course um
i heard that your dad had a quote where
he used to ask you about the peak
and the pit every day yeah so
every dinner that we would have my dad
would ask us what is the peak
and the pit of your day and we would say
the highs and the lows of our days
and even now my dad passed away years
ago in 2003 and even
now we still when we have our family
dinners and
we make sure to do that every time we're
at a family dinner with one another it's
just really a nostalgic thing for us to
do and also
it gives people that dialogue that
sometimes becomes stale
and we all go around the table and we do
it and now that we have
a whole group of all of the nieces and
nephews and all the kids
um it's fun that they get in on it and
they really look forward to telling us
their peak in the pit of the day and
it's so sweet what kids
choose to be you know their highlights
of their days and a lot of the time they
say you know what i don't really think i
have a pet and that's i think the best
part of it
do you remember the last peek and pit of
your beautiful daughter true
she is gonna be three in april
so she doesn't really get like what peek
and pit means so i just you know i say
it more in her terms but
everything is about frozen and elsa so
that is what she talks to me about and
she doesn't say anything
bad like i don't think you know at her
age she's
which i'm so happy about she doesn't
like really
there's nothing that correlates to what
is bad for her
and i love that i want to keep that as
long as possible
yeah cause she will my girls definitely
have
they're gonna be seven and nine and
it's like everything's changing so much
it's
it's so wild but it all gets better it's
i don't
i don't feel at least so far in my
journey with my kids that there's been
one point in their lives that was less
exciting than another
because you're always learning it's
always revealing itself and blooming
like the most
beautiful flower in your garden that
you're cultivating
you i agree i'm a little afraid for
teenage years because
i definitely gave my mom a challenging
time when i was a teenager so i just
you know i think i have a lot of good
karma just the older i've gotten i try
to really be good
and you know just treat people the way i
want to be treated the golden rule so
i'm just really hoping
that my good karma's gonna outweigh the
naughty things i did as a teenager and i
don't get that
put onto me i swear i think about the
same
thing absolutely i know what i was up to
in life
you